paracetamol or acetaminophen as it's
known commercially
is one of the most widely used
over-the-counter drugs for pain relief
in the world due to its easy access it's
also commonly used in intentional
overdose paracetamol reduces pain by
inhibiting enzymes in the cox pathway
when you have an injury like a pulled
muscle this trauma damages cells which
release a host of enzymes one enzyme in
particular called phospholipase breaks
down phospholipids in the cell membrane
into arachidonic acid arachidonic acid
is then converted into prostaglandins by
cox enzymes
these newly made prostaglandins then
signal healing mechanisms like fever and
vasodilation and blood vessels
treating the injured tissue but also
causing pain as a result
paracetamol reduces pain by slowing the
activity of the cox enzymes this
decreases the production of arachidonic
acid
into prostaglandins less prostaglandins
means there's less signaling therefore
reducing pain
when taken in correct doses paracetamol
is quite safe and very
useful the maximum limit for a grown
adult is 4 grams per day or about 8
pills
however when taken in large quantities
it becomes toxic and potentially fatal
toxic doses are estimated to be about 10
grams for an adult or
20 pills but to know how paracetamol
overdose works you first have to
understand how it's broken down in the
body
paracetamol is metabolized in the liver
into three different products
at different amounts it's converted into
paracetamol glucuronide at 55 percent
paracetamol sulfate at 30 percent and
paracetamol glutathione at 15
all three products are non-toxic but
there is a catch
when you take too much paracetamol
paracetamol glutathione becomes a very
crucial part of the equation
before it's made into paracetamol
glutathione it's made into a precursor
called n-acetylp benzoquinone amine or
more simply
napkin napkin is extremely toxic to the
liver and causes severe damage in large
quantities
luckily under normal conditions this
precursor is quickly converted into the
non-toxic paracetamol glutathione
it's when someone overdoses that this
pathway becomes unbalanced
in an overdose the first two pathways
become overwhelmed and can't keep up
with the incoming paracetamol this
excess supply is rerouted to the third
pathway normally this pathway produces
the least amount of metabolite just 15
percent
but now it's saturated since there's
more paracetamol in the third pathway
more toxic napkin is being produced this
massive spike in napkin is what causes
paracetamol poisoning
now things start to get really bad in
order for the napkin to be converted
into non-toxic
paracetamol glutathione a glutathione
group has to be bound to it
one small problem the supply of
glutathione in the liver is quickly
depleted as this pathway is not normally
used to this extent
when glutathione stores run out toxic
neptune builds up in the liver
causing necrosis extensive tissue damage
in the liver leads to liver failure
and once you've hit liver failure you're
done for
there's two possible routes you will end
at the first is systemic necrosis
when your liver becomes necrotic nearby
organs also become necrotic and begin to
fail as well
eventually the patient succumbs to
systemic organ failure through necrosis
the second route is actually heart
failure when the liver dies
circulation in the organ slows down
until it eventually stops
from clotting on the blood vessels with
blood flow being unable to pass through
the liver blood backs up into the
hepatic portal vein
all the way up into the inferior vena
cava blood backs up into the heart and
fills up the right ventricle
extending the heart muscles with so much
backed up pressure that the ventricle
can't pump the blood out the patient
then succumbs to right side heart
failure
so to say the least paracetamol
poisoning is a very slow and painful way
to go
surprisingly numerous case studies have
shown that paracetamol poisonings have
very low fatality rates with only one in
one hundred thousand
being fatal it's this low for a couple
of reasons firstly
it takes a long time for napkin toxicity
to take effect
in the liver sometimes as long as 24
hours
so people having second thoughts have
time to get medical attention
when liver damage does manifest it
becomes noticeable as an acute pain in
the right upper quadrant of the
patient's abdomen
caused by tissue damage in the liver
it's this growing pain in the abdomen
that causes most people to
realize that paracetamol overdose is
actually very slow and painful
and seek medical attention the second
reason paracetamol poisoning fatalities
are
so low is because the medical treatment
to reverse it
is very responsive patients are given
anesthesial cysteine or nac
which resupplies the glutathione stores
so the liver can convert napkin into the
non-toxic paracetamol glutathione
here's some case studies to prove this
in the pan-african journal of medicine
there was a case where a 24 year old
female
ingested 50 grams of paracetamol more
than three times the fatal dosage the
woman was given nac for three days and
was later discharged with no significant
effects of liver damage
in a different study a 64 year old woman
ingested 104 grams of paracetamol
seven times above the fatal limit she
was treated with nac for several days
and was later discharged now this isn't
to say that paracetamol overdose can't
be fatal
it certainly can be it's just that the
rate of poisoning is very slow and due
to time and effects on the body
people have time to seek medical
attention